and the thing is is that like if you
look at patriarchal regimes across the
whole world right now women can't create
anything without a man
nothing they can't create anything they
can't just step out of nowhere and just
create feminism feminism has to be
supplanted by men
it has to be undefended so but what
percent of men partic partook in making
those laws versus what percent of women
participated in it listen I think I
think a lot of men I think I think
listen at the end of the day there's
things get shifted and changed due to
money and men wanting vagina that's why
they say [__] runs the world
because of simp ass men that can't
control the goddamn eggplant [__] don't
change in here without men [__] will
never change in those other patriarchal
regimes unless men allow it to